hello Gordon Ramsay here and I'm teaming
up with a Mensa fly you and again to Los
Angeles for taping of my new show the
f-word and since it'll be my special
guest I'll see you at the VIP table and
when these up after the show maybe
you'll even be inspired to insult a
terrible plate of food but don't worry
if you haven't criticized food before
because I've told countless chefs how to
insult dishes and I'm happy to teach you
now you may not know this but in
addition to being a convict I'm also the
founder of the Gordon Ramsay Academy of
kitchen outrage come on I'll show you
what we do here right up Jamie a sheet
tray up this is chilling just roasted
smoked I think I've been kind of I guess
one yet I just topped it oh no I've
gotta say Oh whoopsie Daisy Oh excellent
seven books up Daisy yeah are you
wearing a diaper now met up a little bit
come on all right listen this chicken
chicken doesn't drop you not drops again
thank Allah for human does a donkey oh
okay all right welcome back Jeremy ugly
I bet not that funny now much like my
students here I'll help you sharpen your
skills to the point where people will be
afraid to have you over for dinner right
porkchop you described them Oh and more
like for LA oh stop it
it's [ __ ] now I'm not wearing a hearing
aid Shh louder yes
don't point at me you described that
[ __ ] there's poo poo I'll say I've got
like young man look at the white in my
eyes and tell me it [ __ ] touch my nose
now say it [ __ ]
kissing they said won't we clear a very
intimate
into much said it's things like Township
now but you're coming from outside us
click the white organdy some foreign
language insult for years
Oh super fit Demelza better Mel Mel Mel
Mel Mel ha ha ha ha man nephew you also
get to bring a friend with you to LA
which is just because I also find and
the work desk as a team sports right
please enjoy this amazing roar asparagus
with a delicious tomato foam why don't
you go yourself you did
brilliant brilliant and important
by the end of our time together
trust me when she was any dish anywhere
at any time right about five minutes
complete your example the time starts
when I serve your dish understood yeah
dishes
pineapple pizza click the link or go to
remain calm / cause to enter now every
entry supports a Great Ormond Street
Hospital children's charity through the
Gordon and panorama foundation - see you
soon
[Music]